uh can i
have we started yet no no let's start
now um
uh cause i got a hat
but i just noticed we're all right
put your hat on because it's there's one
little a little damp and the
top lighting is going to look thin
and uh oh it's going to look thick yeah
there's nothing we can do about it i'm
44. there's plenty of [ __ ] you could do
about it there's things you can can't
spray paint just
come on that's what we do when we're
shooting that's what everybody does
we're in hollywood that's the secret
they just take spray paint spray your
hair off
yeah most people don't realize that like
almost nobody else and every female act
actor is wearing a wig
oh the vast majority well if if you're
on a tv show and you're and you're one
of the leads and you're an actress uh
you're most likely wearing a wig and
that's not because you don't have good
hair it's because getting your hair done
every single morning destroys your hair
it destroys it
it's also so much faster to just uh just
pop away staple the wig on and then why
aren't we doing that i know but it's
another reason for audience members
to watch this [ __ ] that we're
putting out there into the world and and
not try to live up to like imagine like
a woman looking at another actor's hair
and being like oh i wish my hair was as
thick and luxurious yeah but it's a wig
it's a wig it's a wig i'll tell you what
too in terms of like the men out there
pretty much like all your all my
favorite actors don't have luxurious
hair like when i really think about it
right right right people that i like the
best character actors yeah they just let
it go they just let it go yeah why
aren't you letting yours go
because i won't look good on me
see that's what everybody thinks but
that's what he said i think it would
look great i think yeah i'll start
letting it go you know what i will say
there's there's certain there's a shade
in my head by the way i have no idea
what it would look like i could have i
think the other eyeball no no listen
listen you've got a good shaped head i
can tell we've already talked about it
we've talked about it you've got a great
way you don't know what's under there
well that's true it could be all lumpy
it could be a lumpy it could be bumpy
wumpy other than these people have lumpy
heads that's weird yeah that would be
good character [ __ ] you'd be like oh man
that kind of a lumpy head yeah that's
cool i like i see that dude with the
lumpy head yeah but then he's limited to
only playing lumpy headed characters
otherwise they gotta like fill it in
with like you know you can make a whole
sitcom about that the lumps yeah the
lumpies the lumpies that's even better
um i will say there are certain balding
patterns that i think are more
attractive than others like i would say
the least attractive balling pattern and
this is the most unfortunate in many
ways is when you've got somebody with a
full head of hair
and then it's just missing right and
then just it starts to go like right
here like i i would prefer to go bald in
the way that jack nicholson went bald
where it just goes it goes here it's
cool yeah it just looks cooler you have
like a [ __ ] point in the front but
it's also bald in the back too you just
don't notice it yet yeah yeah yeah i
think that's what's happening with me
yeah oh same here i'm i'm i'm thinning
in the crown it's not fun i think like
the the i mean this has never been thick
but when i turn around right now the
three of us are it's a nightmare
that's a nightmare back there the
mystery will be gone yeah yeah it's
gonna all almost all
half a century
i almost lost my mind last night because
i know you have a birthday coming up
this weekend right i do and you're old i
almost [ __ ] myself yeah i know
you're an old man but you don't look it
i know yeah
i know but i'll tell you why why because
uh tom mary uh day
did not look old until like i don't know
like like their late 60s early 70s and
then they look now they look 107. but it
was just like it took a minute yeah they
just had these jeans that they kind of
like young young young young and then
wham
really old baseball bat of age
so my theory about how to like not upset
the audiences just always be on camera
you know never stop being on camera oh
right so there's no gap there's no gap
it's the gap that throws people off like
when a guy goes away for a while then
comes back and people are like oh [ __ ]
jesus christ what happened to that guy
yeah but if you're watching if you watch
people slowly deteriorate you're fine
with it yeah yeah you're good with it
yeah well in terms of like dyeing the
gray hair that i have like there was a
time where i was doing it on the sh on
the various shows
sunny and mythicquest isn't a show i do
on apple and i uh will
will paint the grays out or i'll dye
them and then i would tell myself well
no i'm just doing the character like the
characters you know we want to stay like
a certain thing and then i was doing it
and then we would stop shooting and then
i would continue doing it and then i
would look at other other guys and be
like oh he looks cool he's going like
salt and pepper that looks that looks
good yeah but then i'm like you can't
well it's hard to pull the trigger on it
when you're an actor like you're like
you want to convince yourself like i
want to convince myself that i can still
play a guy in his like mid-30s if i
really wanted to but let's be honest i
mean you know yeah so i'm i'm actually
i'm actually letting the grays come
through here a little bit um
i'm not sure if i'm gonna fully commit
to that but um
but like this part right here is
on top i'm still you know pretty dark
but like here yeah it's pretty great for
the listener at home here was the side
of his head oh yeah sorry sorry for the
side of my but i you know it occurred to
me like uh because i was you know sort
of going through this like well i hope
no one's actually sorry listening to
this part we're going to cut all this
so [ __ ]
[Music]
do we want to hard right into this
week's episode what do you want to talk
about somebody to talk about the poll
okay let's jump back a little bit
because i have a little bit of an issue
with the poll right now oh really
yeah i've got an issue with the poll
okay i feel he was a little bit biased
because a lot of the comments that i was
reading were like based on people's
opinions well no it was
no it was it was can you say what paul
you're talking about i'm sorry okay so
we had a poll
on the internet on instagram
instagram yeah on youtube everywhere oh
okay twitter uh and it was just a thumbs
up or thumbs down if you liked if you
thought the clicks was funny or or if
you thought the click's right
this is the [ __ ] problem okay that is
not what i was saying that is not what i
was saying what i was saying was what i
didn't like was the actual shooting of
the gun the clicks i like
now this is where the pole got biased
because people misunderstood and they
thought because and because you did say
you were like
uh you know the firing is funny but
what's
i think you maybe even said what's even
funnier is that when he runs out of
bullets and the clicks afterwards and i
didn't respond to that i just kept going
was like no it's not funny
but what i meant was that the actual
shooting of the gun is what i didn't
find funny the clicks i found funny but
then i would also like to clarify i do
think it would be funny if
it click if it clicked five times if he
was gesturing with it and it clicked
five times and then on the last one he
he
went off like he forgot there was one in
his mouth though he shoots one and then
he goes
two three four
five with the clicks and then the last
one is six no he shoots the gun like
[ __ ] six times
and no one's ready
that's not going off in the room which
it wasn't so wait meg what was the
actual question can we hear it it was uh
is danny firing the gun funny or does it
ruin the scene
okay so that's the other problem
i never saw it on the scene i never see
you guys
but i never but i want to be clear about
this also i never said that it ruined
the scene so this is why i feel like the
poll was biased it was like it was
almost like you said like you may as
well have said like was danny firing the
gun funny or is danny on the show not
funny
you know what i mean like i didn't say
that the scene wasn't funny you were
saying that the poles seemed clear
results of this voting
uh
okay yes it was therefore
it's null and void okay i will say that
the comment i liked the best was that
they said the more that glenn talks
about how not funny it is the funnier it
becomes right
this will just make it funny i get that
i will say though to your credit i think
out of you know the whatever like say
107 people liked it
you know there's two or three dudes that
agreed agree with you that they didn't
like it now yes and the ones that agreed
said i didn't like it because i felt
like the gun going off was ridiculous
basically were there comments and i was
like that's the only thing that's the
creative process that's the whole thing
so like when we come into an editing
room we're like okay we have a funny
idea and there is no is when it comes to
ideas about jokes there's no like
factual this is funny that's not funny
it's all it's all
it's pinging you and it's pinging you as
too fast to be funny and rob and i are
thinking it's true enough to get away
with and be funny totally and that's and
yeah listen and i'm i'm hyperbolic i
admit you know what i'm saying like
you're dug in i'm reactive no no no i'm
not dug in i'm not dead you're not
staggering you're not i promise you i'm
not dug in i swear to god i'm not but i
am hyperbolic
you know i mean like so it may have come
off like i was saying you know that the
scene was ruined but uh that was not my
intention i don't think the scene was
ruined anyway should we move past the
pole yeah
i mean i don't know
i think we want to keep things going
right
now
i saw more than anything else about well
way more comments uh about
um
about that episode had nothing to do
with the dry firing and more to do with
uh glenn slowly morphing into dennis in
various episodes and how much people
like i want to challenge that okay
because there is the the raging angry
golden god dennis which we found and
love and love to use in the show
that character is not in this episode
that we watched uh that we're gonna be
discussing today he is not a raging man
yeah and he's a delightful guy in this
episode so there are other sides to the
dennis character that i think we should
embrace i'm not talking about the dennis
character i'm talking about glenn on the
podcast well yes but i'm saying the same
as the listeners and viewers are in the
show
we lean too hard into one lane god it
gets sold you know don't poke the bear
let the bear come out when the barrel
okay okay well because also like you
know i mean i think if the bear knows
it's gonna be poked it's not good
no it will it will still
okay okay now i can lick that off later
yeah i mean just poking me with a stick
what is this a regular stick with no
honey on it how many times do you think
you can poke a bear with a stick before
it starts to slash at you
i think you say
not that many i think you could get six
pokes in
it's the bear asleep is the bear hybrid
you know have you covered yourself in
something to cover up your smell does he
know you're there you're just you and
and so he can smell you in the scenario
the bear's not around it's not
protecting his child right the bear's
just doing his best they're like
foraging for whatever it's it's it's a
good mood this is 20 22 so it's used to
people everywhere and you go up to the
bear and you're in the park and you're
like wow i'm getting right up to this
bear yeah and you poke it with a stick
once and the bear's like huh what the
[ __ ] was that yeah you know what i mean
you poke it again and the bear's like oh
what's this guy doing you poke it a
third time the bear's like
i'm getting a little agitated that's
three you broke it a fourth time the
bear's like is this guy serious they're
taking [ __ ] cause he's checking it
for honey though i mean like no he poked
it the fifth time and the bear's like
all right dude forget this guy i'm gonna
have to tell you i might have to teach
him a lesson you broke it the sixth time
and the bear is like you're dead
so you think he wants him you get and
then he's like five folks of the bear i
said he's saying i think you could poke
a bear six times before explain the
price
he got away with it five times
and on the sixth time he got swept yeah
yeah
i think with about at least like a six
foot stick i'm not saying you know like
it's so close to you because the bear's
got you know well you're gonna wanna you
wanna be you wanna do this safely one
two you wanna stab the bear with a stick
safe from a safe distance yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah disclaimer guys there is
no safe
distance to poke a bear nor is it
appropriate to poke any animals you
probably just poke it once in reality
guys this episode brought to you by
peeta
um here's another thing too rob have you
been watching the episodes i kind of
watch every episode now being like i
wonder if rob's actually watching son of
a [ __ ] no not only
brought our trust no
totally fair not only have i watched
every episode i went back and watched
the politics you did yes yes i did yes i
did and and also now i've recruited
caitlyn to watch them as well she's
of like half the [ __ ] that's that's
happening like the knives thing from
this episode actually can we talk about
that for a second so as i recall i mean
the the whole thing of us doing the
countdown that was not in the script no
because we're laughing that happened
yeah you guys are just [ __ ] straight
up straight up laughing but it totally
works yeah yeah yeah because you're like
they would be laughing at yeah the
potential throwing knives that they yeah
i
i have a thing where i watch the
episodes and this is just a
creative weakness
but where every time i watch i i have
this like battle in my mind of like were
we better were we doing it better was
this funnier like do you guys have that
do you struggle at all with that i
struggle with that all the time no i'm
just constantly comparing stuff in my
and then doubting which i think that's
really just fear and death the first two
seasons i felt that
i definitely did not feel that um i felt
we were doing it better now most of the
times i was watching it and i'm like i
get why that was funny at the time but
it's not that's not i would never make
that joke now
uh once now that we're into season three
like this last episode dennis and dee's
mom is dead uh that one made me laugh
from start to finish and i was like i
stand by this this is a really good
episode like
this is i think the first time that we
started making every character a little
bit stupid
you know i mean danny's reaction to
hugging when he finds out that that
stephen collins has been working with
people with aids
i completely forgot about that also look
can we talk about his perform like this
this is such a great actor the standing
veto guy yeah we found we got we we
struck goals and we just struggled
you found this guy i can't believe he's
close nobody had ever you know
discovered this guy before i mean he's
incredible but like no his his turn from
like you know going from the grift to
just immediately like i'm dropping it
age you thought did you touch anybody
just i mean that's so stupid for his
character and i i love that now there's
a guest actor in this episode and i
don't want to name the person because
the this the story i'm going to tell is
sort of a personal story uh
but
it was this actor's first ever audition
for anything oh yeah well so we had met
him
i guess after season one or two and uh
well he's friends with our makeup artist
leah voltron and he said that he had his
first ever audition for a movie
television anything
and it was for our show
and um he went our casting director at
the time was a guy named john pepsidera
when we started the show and he goes to
john pepsidera's office and he's as
nervous as can be right he's never
auditioned for anything
and
he's got his head shots and he's he's he
knows his lines he's ready to go and
suddenly he has this like rumble on the
stomach of like you know and that like
tastes in your mouth and the sweat of
like tasting well i don't know just like
the dried taste in your mouth okay yeah
like a dry mouth situation that you're
the watery the watery yeah that's
usually vodka yeah that's vomiting
that's not where this is all right sorry
well this is coming out the other end
so he realizes he he's going to have
diarrhea like he's like there's no way
i'm not having diarrhea and it's
vomiting it's coming really bad
and yeah it's coming
yeah so he goes to the bathroom but just
before he gets to there uh someone some
actor actress goes in and they lock the
door and he's he's waiting he's waiting
and he can kind of hear the person in
there like rehearsing their lines and
they're taking forever
and he like taps on the door but they're
not coming out and then he's like i'm
not gonna make it i'm not gonna make it
so he goes in the alleyway behind the
casting office
and he's like a dumpster there and he
he doesn't quite make it he he has diary
in his pants he pulls his pants down
and he's like oh my god this is a mess
this is amazing
he's trying to salvage the situation he
has no toilet paper so he's wiping his
butt with his own headshots
and the sides and yeah pieces of paper
and photographs of himself he's wiping
his ass with pictures of himself
there's never been a greater metaphor
for hollywood yeah
it's something out of like you know like
a ben stiller absolutely
straight out of a yeah and so
as the story goes he realizes
i'm done there's there's no i can't do
the audition i got to go home
and
he gets in his car and his pants are so
ruined and they're smelling the car
smell so bad that he like takes them off
and like i don't know if he throws them
out the window whatever but he's driving
home and no pants on and as he's driving
home with no pants on he gets rear-ended
oh my god
he gets rear-ended now the rest is kind
of hazing for me like i remember there's
like a homeless guy who looks in the
window and starts yelling like that
dude's got no pants on and anyway so we
heard the story and then i think we had
it he auditioned again he because we
didn't just like automatically give him
a part we had to make sure he could i
think yeah i know he auditioned for that
he did but we we found out about it
after he had auditioned that's right so
we probably would have just given it to
him anyway because of that but then he
redforton was great and we were like yes
you hit you have earned this role do you
guys have any terrible audition stories
like your worst auditions you ever went
into
that's a good question oh god we're
saudi so many yeah but nothing like that
right no nothing where your pants were
filled with diarrhea or you you
yeah it's like
to go from that any story is going to be
a step down at this point from that
story i think that's
i barely remember uh my days of
auditioning right it's crazy it's like a
whole different era of my life i do
remember i constantly rejected rejection
i had been given the terrible advice uh
i was a sophomore in college and i
decided oh maybe i want to go to acting
school and so i applied to bu
and i did the audition
and i remember
the one acting teacher at my college
gave me some pretty bad advice which was
he's like you don't have to do a
monologue do a scene and just do your
half of the scene
so
so yeah yeah i know it's really bad
advice so i did i did something like
from hurley burley and like
i would say like my line and then
pretend i was hearing a response
so i'd be like it's the menus karen you
know like you you're not even looking at
the menu
pause
oh really
oh really you
you would say that you
like of course
yeah well i didn't get in of course it
didn't go well it didn't go well
[Music]
um the dick flyer we got to talk about
the dick flyer yes let's talk about the
dick flyer do you guys remember whose
idea was that i i don't remember who
came up with that is that that feels
like a martyr roselle joke to me well i
don't know i think uh i think we were
talking about uh i think i i think it
occurred to us in the moment like we
were pitching different ideas like what
should the shape of the flyer be and
somebody pitched a bicep and then i
think somebody was like if you turn that
upside down yeah that would probably
look like a dong
and then uh you know because that was
who we were
and still are uh we decided that that
was the funniest shape for the for the
flyer it absolutely is i can't imagine a
better joke for that sequence there are
a lot of things i feel like from this
episode that sort of endured and stayed
um none of which i can now recall him
remember he's dead well that whole scene
i mean what i love about that particular
scene when we're talking about all the
all the people that we're going to
invite to the party mansion and
like to me it distills exactly what we
were trying to do which is like these
guys
the joke isn't oh isn't it funny that
these guys are like homophobic that
wasn't it at all it's that they don't
even realize what they're doing no right
there because they're so stupid
so
that's like perfectly distilled in that
scene in the party mansion where we're
where i open up my flip phone and i'm
like i'm gonna like go through my
contacts list and i only have two
numbers saved dennis and charlie and
then everybody else that we talk about
we have either burned
or has killed themselves or doesn't want
to hang out with us and then we go and
torture these other two people to show
that like
the the this is how we alienated
ourselves the first time we took the
characters to that place where we're
like these people are so extreme that
they've actually alienated everyone
by the way all those names were like
college buddies of mine all those those
yeah everybody had a nickname and you
brought you stash who got his nickname
because he was afraid of pistachios
i thought that was a mustache yeah yeah
no it was a pistachio reference
i just remember on that day which we
shot in that actual house that we that's
in the in the exterior shot um nick grad
who is the executive at fx
who's basically like the the boss right
we came that day yeah and i remember he
was behind the monitors it was the first
time that fx because they kind of like
were pretty hands off and they would
just be like okay just deliver the
episodes
and he was like no i live in the area so
he came by that day and i remember us
not being able to get through that scene
we were laughing so hard and like that
we were like wasting so much time in the
bloopers yeah and i just remember at one
point looking over at nick who was
sitting at the producer's monitors and
he was laughing as hard as we were he
was like crying last night
yes and i was like don't face nick i was
like yeah thank god like we if if nick
is laughing right at this then i think
we're in good shape
makes a good laugher i mean not so much
yeah like a business pitch meeting but
like uh like yeah yeah yeah yeah
he's here he's hearing them all day
but when you're seeing the actual goods
you're seeing the performance it's funny
if you were pitching that scene to him
it wouldn't be as funny mm-hmm
yeah i noticed this was the first
episode i think credited to matt shakman
yeah i i yeah i think so matt shackman
who uh to quote the big lebowski
directed the bulk of the series bulk of
the series dude welcome the series bulk
of the series yeah at least for a while
i don't know if anything well he's
definitely still moved on to mad men and
game of thrones and yeah he does uh
what's that disney show one division
he directed all the one divisions matt
jackman god i miss that guy yeah i love
him so much he's brian hunger
brian he's an amazing fan and this is
the first scene with the lawyer yeah and
he like i feel like he got
our
humor like immediately he understood
exactly what was funny about it and then
made it way funnier than it was even on
the patreon in that scene where he's
reading the will and you're yelling at
him about the will
and then you're yelling at him to tell
barbara stuff yes yeah even though you
know that she's dead yeah
i remember i remember sitting with
hornsby i mean hornsby and i are
credited with writing the episodes but
as we've said many many times nobody
really
we're all writing it together but i do
remember being in a room with hornsby
and figuring out the idea that it would
be funny if they were not not
clearly misunderstanding but almost like
subconsciously misunderstanding that
this man was not the person who was
actually writing the words that he was
saying and that they could somehow
connect back to barbara and communicate
with barbara that's how like locked off
they are yeah yeah
and it works yeah it works really funny
the pauses he takes when he's like your
fat monkey heart yes when he realizes
he's about to read something that's
going to trigger a response
he's like
it's like i have to read this i have to
i wonder how how many episodes has he
done
six five six we haven't had him
have we had him on i feel like the last
time we had him on was when we did that
uh
the trial or the big fake trial scene
yeah mcpoyle versus him back because i
love him so much six episodes six that's
it god i feel like he's been in so many
well we talk about him a bit like we're
always threatening each other with like
i'm going to call him right he's going
to come in and fix it for us because
he's my lawyer he's my lawyer
[Laughter]
no matter how many times he undermines
us we're he's still our guy that's our
guy well we expect that from you expect
that from a lawyer right sure you like
it anyway um what else i'm gonna consult
my notes here guys i i had uh ross print
out my notes so that doesn't look like
i'm just looking at my phone i love that
there's a little bit more professional
that's good ask a question
you know what i really like about this i
like that well first of all we do
something that we don't normally do we
did a little bit in the politics episode
but when we cut
outside in the hallway and bruce mathis
is walking away and he calls tracy or
whatever his assistant and says unclear
or who he's calling clear yeah and says
clear my schedule i'm gonna i'm gonna
teach my
my daughter a lesson
and then and then we watch as he tries
to do that but at every turn i was
watching with kaitlyn last night and i
was like wait what so he says i'm gonna
need you two to make love right yeah
so the assumption is the character is
thinking there's no way they're gonna
take it this far right and then you cut
to them in ropes on the bed and i was
like just as we're as we're thinking
about what those characters are thinking
why they took it already this far yeah
and then i i was like this is so stupid
why would they why would we assume that
the characters would go this far with it
i remembered us having a similar
conversation when we were writing it and
then we were like let's lean all the way
into that which is that the whole point
of the story is to watch as bruce mathis
tries to push them as far as he possibly
can and they keep going all the way
through with it yeah all the way along
with it yeah to the point where he says
let's get married and let's get i'll
marry you and they say okay and then
they do it and he can't believe it
because there's no there's no he can't
go any further there's no yeah there's
no line that they're not going to cross
over i remember debating whether or not
to keep the phone call in right so we
have a yes a moment where he's in the
hallway and he says i'm gonna teach
these guys a lesson is it better if we
know that he knows and he's doing a
thing or is it or is it better if we
don't know that he's doing a thing um
that was the right i feel like nowadays
we wouldn't keep that little bit of
phone call in we would say let's let the
audience connect those dots in their
mind that
but it is a good setup for the comedy of
those scenes which is probably why we
ultimately
i think it's good yeah i think it's
funnier that we know what he's doing i
stand by that choice but i think if we
didn't do it if we wouldn't put that
scene in now it would only be because we
just don't cut to characters
outside of our characters or we would
assume that you you'd either you'd
either know right you'd either watch and
be like i bet he's doing this
or you wouldn't know you'd watch and you
say well i don't know he might be doing
that he might be not and then it's a fun
reveal when you find out that he was
right glenn we cut outside of our uh
main characters on friday
um on the podcast our main characters
being you me and charlie we cut outside
when you left we uh we cut outside of
you and we we
we called we had a a listener call in
who's a big part of the show
and it was fine
but you know what's better with you who
well thank you yeah you almost got
replaced by
who called in caitlyn olson
yeah all we heard was
i mean it was unlistable it's bad enough
we got to listen to meg's voice now we
got to listen to hers too it's like good
lord i can't
dudes only bros
only you know what um i disagree i love
women
i was so happy when we did the call-in
show and really hard working with you
for so long just because of how toxic
that's very toxic yeah it's just so
toxic toxic and megan i'm sorry for your
toxic
friend here yeah yeah so you have to put
up with them i know it's different
thanks guys so much chopstick um
no one knows what top stick is yeah
unless they're you're like a costume is
that what people put on for like their
toupees i i might need to look into that
mm-hmm when you're looking at top stick
it's it's it's uh i believe it's
double-sided tape two-sided tape yeah so
if you've got a shirt if you're in a
scene and you've got a shirt with
buttons
and it's it's bunching in that little
hole that little hole sometimes they'll
come and put a little top stick on there
yep to keep stick your shirt together
they stick your hair on this thing
once again the audience is at home going
like how does he get his shirt in
between the buttons so flat
my sense of self-worth is destroyed by
the fact that that man can keep his
shirt so strong yeah mine's always pop
stick it's just top stick yeah
everything's top stick you're sticking
hair on yeah you're sticking makeup on
you're sticking tan stuff on you're
sticking
you know somebody else's clothes on you
got makeup on you got makeup on you got
you know yeah it's a whole thing it's
awesome someone's writing it
like you're like creating like the
illusion of like a fake reality of life
or something you know it's almost like
you're trying to do that right yeah
right you know what i appreciate i
appreciate that the rock is bringing
back baggy clothes you know what i mean
like he wears [ __ ] that's like is he
have you seen his [ __ ] he he'll put a
suit on his shirt shirt will be tight
right but his pants
holy [ __ ] he's got some nice pants it's
[ __ ] baggy
sweet yeah they have to be specially
made right i mean how do you oh yeah
everything's specially made for the rock
come on come on how tall is he
is he tall also no no no he's four eight
he's four yeah yeah yeah he's better
yeah they always have to stand really
close to camera so he seems big and the
rest of the cast is way far behind
but he's right up there right up close
to lens and they make tiny cars for him
to drive around and
tiny muscle cars
rob's laughing because he knows that i
told us like some kid this once like uh
i like oh man a long time ago maryland
was like working at the ymca i think it
was like season one of sunday and like
some kid was like oh what you do i'm
like huh he said what do you do i'm like
i don't know i'm like i'm an actor he's
like you ever met vin diesel i'm like oh
yeah dude he's like he is he badass i'm
like no he's really small
so what are you talking about like he's
really tiny man he's like
what what about those those cars he
drives like they make tiny cars for they
look like tiny little
cars we're gonna drive around
i don't know the internet says he's six
five dwayne johnson wow wow is he really
that's what the internet says but if you
want to look up what the internet says
you guys yeah let's see what you're
saying about us and see if it's
see yeah i know it's not the internet
says i'm 510 and i'm not you taller
than me i am taller
why is the internet shortened you
i don't know why the internet would do
that to me i don't dare how dare the
internet
i'm 5 10 and a half i'll tell you what
some [ __ ] on the internet uh that
those whole net worth things oh oh those
are fun those are fun those are fun but
they're total [ __ ] i wish they were
real
yeah they're not real
uh megan what's our what's our net worth
yeah
what's wrong what's our first term
how tall am i
wait although let's guess this are they
going to guess you taller or
shorter or dead or right i'm actually
not even certain how tall you are five
seven with a pair of shoes on take my
shoes off i'm probably five six and
three quarters we're talking about with
no shoes on the the internet says five
seven for you charlie okay
five ten what the [ __ ]
and glenn 510 as well oh we're the same
oh we're the same height yeah yeah yeah
that's cool the internet says it
the internet it says it is so it claims
that charlie's worth 30 million dollars
oh my can i take that can i cash that in
wow can i take that to the bank i mean i
don't know that's something [ __ ]
man
i should be you should have 30 minutes
god damn it yeah how much how much do do
i have uh
it says rob's worth 50 million
what
why are you working what's going on
almost double uh what well is that 125.
the internet hates you man it hurts that
hurts the internet thinks you're sure
and poor we'll see okay so
but this is what the internet does isn't
it it takes the takes the biggest star
and tries to tear them
man they made the down 6'5
he must be like 7 10. what is crazy
about that [ __ ] though is that how often
we'll we'll recognize right that all of
those numbers are off and yet when
someone's like hey did you know that the
rock what does it say the rock was worth
yeah because whatever the number is yeah
whatever i believe i believe i'll
believe it and it'll still be uh it says
800 million
i don't believe i actually don't believe
it get out of here am i familiar with
taxes and all the all the people that he
he's got his territory
have he's no i don't think they haven't
sold ceremony yet but i think it's it's
some something like four times
like the i think it's like but if it's
called celebrity net worth right yeah
okay so that means that after you're
you're saying that he's made one point i
mean 1.6 billion dollars i think that's
possible no no more than more than that
more than that yeah because the agents
and you know you know yeah he's not
taking home 50 so he's so you're saying
the rock his income has been well over
two billion dollars yeah i think if you
can if you look at his movies his movies
his endorsements his energy drink his
tequila his shoes his
clothes
the man is rocking it he's right he's
rocking it he's rocking him two billion
dollars is a lot of income why are you
getting more money because of caitlyn
because of caitlyn no
it's not his combined that's not
combined i don't know is it combined
let's see if caitlyn olson has her own
separate because now we're about to add
these together guys oh she's got her own
separate we're going to take the 50 and
oh no it says 50 million for her too
oh that's combined that's all yeah oh
that's how they did it yeah net worth is
combined with her husband yeah
yeah okay
see my my wife makes documentaries about
social issues so she's not making
millions and millions of dollars but she
is making the world a better place by
the way it says she's five eight
caitlin she's that's probably right
she's about right yeah oh really yeah
she's probably fine yeah i'm i'm
honestly i'm five nine so i'm i'm an
inch i think i'm an inch taller than her
because when she wears heels she's
taller than me oh yeah
yeah towers over here oh where where she
can see that it's embarrassing in every
direction oh yeah she does seem tall
she's a tall lady she's very skinny
she's long five minutes it's not that
tall her her arms are so long right
she's gonna wings
these arms are ridiculous we've measured
her this way so she's got long fingers
too she does so human beings are
supposed to be the exact their exact
height this way right that's right and
and then sometimes there's outliers and
and can you know that i did not know
that
okay so
there are people who are just listening
rob has his arms
uh extended sort of like jesus not
across look and uh and he's saying if
you measure from finger to finger that's
supposed to equal your height yeah yeah
it's all it's almost like it's it's
pretty eerie do we have a tape measure
in this office we can get one if we
don't we might as well do our height
while we're here
and and then
i can't do it but caitlyn has the
wingspan confused right now your
height's different
i'm hunched because of my injury like
i'm i'm literally i'm literally like i
can't it hurts for me to stand up it's
like fully straight still
that's something [ __ ]
that's okay when we're when we're all
able-bodied
we'll take a tape
sorry my shoulder's broken you can't
measure my height no no it's my back
it's my [ __ ] [ __ ] like i i j i've
got weird
my vitruvian spine has been all [ __ ]
up from my snowboarding incident okay
um let me get let's get a tape measure
this is worth doing because it's really
interesting i have one outside okay
let's grab one yeah i think i've always
felt like i had slightly short arms so i
wouldn't be surprised if my wingspan was
shorter than my and my body well let's
find out this is going to be this is
going to be interesting i can't lift
this arm up
yeah well
oh [ __ ]
here's
yeah okay so for the listener who's not
watching this um
shoes are wait is this is this going to
be on camera is this are the cameras
high enough to capture this
well you got to take your hat off bud
i'll go through it yeah yeah yeah this
is shoes on so give or take
your trigger come on straighten that
neck straight yeah there you go get that
chin nice and high okay so we have you
at 67 and a half inches so that's five
foot seven and a half that's five seven
and a half shoes on so but well with
shoes
five foot seven let's call it five foot
seven oh the wingspan now can you okay
so he's holding his arms out uh like
jesus on the cross
and we're gonna see if his wingspan
matches
all right mackel honey let's see what
you got
so now mcelhenny is holding one arm out
but not the other one i'm so happy to
wore my lips today
go to tom cruise's guy right yeah we got
the same guy
yeah let's get the hat and the
headphones off here all right let's uh
let's make sure you don't measure his
hair what's left of it hair could be hot
don't measure what's left of his hair
just measure to the top of his head
here we go megan's megan's assisting i'm
right around 70.
70. so that would be that would be 5 10
but an inch for the shoes probably
because i have
he's got some tall oh i'm five nine you
said five nine three might be five nine
and a half though no or
five nine and a quarter at least anyway
hit it to the door okay
all right now we're doing mcelhenne's
wingspan
we're gonna cut all this um
yeah 69 which would make sense
with the shoes crazy wow that's the
truth i think that's the vitruvian thing
right
the trivia measurement thank you that is
the vitruvian measurement meg
[ __ ] megan would you like to be magical
would you like to be
you don't want to be exploited by men
would you like them to measure you
but i know for a fact that
that meg has mentioned that she's like
sometimes feels self-conscious about
being tall and i'm like it's not that
you're tall it's that we're small like
i'm around
is that why you married the world's
tallest man
i uh i'm 5 10 and a little bit how are
you and my husband's six seven whoa and
first sonny fans he played alan in the
uh sexual harassment episode he's so
funny in that episode he's a very funny
actor what a funny man you guys wrote
the thing about his dick being big
you guys been watching the pam and tommy
thing no is it good
i'm enjoying it great i'm gonna watch it
there's a whole scene where uh spoiler
alert uh where his like penis talks
i heard about that that's [ __ ]
hilarious yeah i was like that's great i
was like okay awesome
finally have we talked about this do
they show it they're showing they show
its little mouth finally the dicks are
sideways man i saw the article today
we're having a penis renaissance there's
been a lot of penises this year yeah
renaissance penis songs good yeah
yeah the penis is back there
glenn's really happy with that
he's very happy i think i think it's
well overdue
that we have a peanut sauce because
we've been showing other stuff for a
long time and it's time to show those
dicks guys it's time to get your dicks
out and show everybody what you've got
yeah not at work not at work
don't take your dick out on no no no
no no no no no but if you're in a movie
take your dick out and let's see what
you've got as long as that's the right
place
they've cleared the set we've agreed
there's a time and a place for
everything and the time and the place is
when you're doing a movie
that's when you take your dick out
hey i got a question for you guys yeah
you know since uh we do a whole scene
with um you know character reading the
will
of
if you guys were to
die suddenly
what would you leave me
would you leave me anything or does it
all go to the family millions of dollars
i've made you what how much are you
worth
25 million
dollars that's a lot of money and that's
pretty much you have you have the two of
us
you're saying
well that's definitely true
yeah
but i have to thank you guys so is there
anything you'd like to leave me charlie
[Laughter]
um i'm trying to think
what you like you could even well you
could even just go ahead i have i
probably have like a nice japanese
whiskey which i know you enjoy
so i could leave you my would you see me
just light that you know i i i actually
just genuinely got a little bit touched
by that yeah
i'm genuinely touched i have my whiskeys
you're touched by the fact that i know
what what it is that you really like yes
and that you would get that you would
give me that that you would yeah that
you would will that to me okay i'll see
if i'll call my uh all right rob what
would you give me
i can't i gotta follow that what would
you give me
what would glenn like
other than whiskey you can make it up
you don't actually do that
no one really knows
what does glenn like
give me a good blender
you could recap that episode and take
the gun shots out oh
that would be really nice wow and and
listen you wouldn't even have to be we
don't have to replace the current one
you just literally give it to me okay
why don't we do that why don't we do
that anyway because it might be
interesting to see the scene
as exactly the way you want it okay so i
think the funniest version for the
record if we're actually gonna do this
is five clicks and then a gunshot i
don't know if there's a way to cut it
that way but we have the technology to
do that of course we could just go back
they'd have to just pull that one
it wouldn't yeah depending on how many
times he fires it and i think he does
fire it probably six times because then
he reloads it and fires it again at the
end yeah
and you can take so stupid the first
thing you could just mute the first yeah
with the flashes don't do we do muzzle
flash i think we did i think we did we
did yeah
but we could go back hey look for you
buddy since you're dead and whatnot
we'll go back and we'll we'll pull those
we'll pull that old footage and we'll
have it re-cut for you well i'm not dead
you're dead you're leaving me something
i'm alive right i still don't understand
that
yeah yeah you know how it works
why you left me something right
you don't leave the dead man
okay so then you have full autonomy to
cut the show any way you want whoa
you would leave me with that right
that's what i'm that's what i'm leaving
the glenn howerton cut
the glenn howerton cut of the whole
[ __ ] series put that in in my will
how about this how about this i put this
in my will
you guys should continue making the show
we've by the way we have actually all
decided that that if one of us dies we
will continue making the show that was
years ago before
we made that we did make that call and
it's not to honor you it's no we want to
continue
making money yeah but how about this if
we if i die
or when i die from some awesome thing
and you guys are still making the show
wait wait wait wait you guys still want
to make the show
oh yeah yeah you guys
that i always side with glenn
holy [ __ ] that'd be so [ __ ] up so he's
got a super majority i have a super
majority
number
and i tend to agree i'm creative that is
true that is true
generally charlie and i disagree and you
no i don't know i don't know that that's
necessary no it's it's generally it
cycles around it cycles it cycles around
yeah yeah but i would say that yeah
it's very rare where there's a scene you
know in the editing room where there's
like gunshots getting put in or whatever
it is and i'm like that's that's just
not that's crazy to me i would say it's
rare that we just that we heavily
disagree on anything yeah you know like
we usually know when something is
working or not can we agree that we've
done the podcast for the day i don't
know about that i don't know how much
something to leave you guys even though
i'm not dead but i have a special treat
for you today you do which is i this
morning
i hard-boiled these eggs in coffee no
[ __ ] way oh no to see whether uh it
would get through so if you guys want to
peel these eggs and then taste them yeah
yeah let's do it see
let's do it you didn't peel it before
you boiled it i did not peel okay so you
just you just boiled uh you just i made
a pot of coffee and then i put the eggs
into the coffee with no extra water just
the coffee
and then i boiled them as i standardly
do
hard-boiled eggs
do you have salt there's no there's no
brown coloration in here though like
with the tea what do you say the tea the
shells are still smelling
they still smell like eggs
see here's that's amazing i think the
tea egg the thing with the tea egg and i
don't know i have to never peel these
well do you guys suck i suck at peeling
harder you gotta use
um
i would say that i think maybe let's
look up how the tea egg is cooked but i
think
what i meant to say
i did uh look that up and actually they
soak it in tea after they hard-boiled
they boil it so oh
so so this is gonna be nothing it's
probably not gonna taste like coffee
this is gonna taste like it smells like
an egg
it just tastes like an egg yeah oh does
it so yeah
so we gotta do it the way they do the
tea you gotta soak it in coffee you
gotta and this is what i meant
when i said do you peel it first you
gotta boil it peel it
and then soak it in some coffee and soak
it but definitely boil it first before
you peel it
well megan
thank you very much
my husband was like what are you doing
and i was like i'm working
here guys wait wait for those freaks out
there let's do a little asmr
why
that doesn't bother me that doesn't
bother you wait let me do it let me see
if i can it won't bother me if you're
doing it on purpose really
right that's what we established chewing
sounds don't bother me not the sound
it's not it's that it's that people
don't give a [ __ ] yes yes it's the it's
the chaos it's the the psychology behind
it being like i don't care what sounds i
make that are invading the space that
was very odd because the sound bugs the
[ __ ] out of me
and whether you are doing it
intentionally or not it's the sound so
this bothers you
yes it does
you know what i'm doing on purpose
you're trying bob there's a lot of
people out there right now that are
[ __ ] really grossed out and then
there's some people that are getting
erections right right right
right
yeah i guess i don't know i don't know
is that what it is like are women into
this mega they're getting turned on it's
only mad at me though
it's a good egg meg thank you yeah
that's a good egg that's good coffee and
these drinks turns out you can boil your
egg and coffee or water and it won't
penetrate the shell boil it in whatever
whatever you're already boiling just go
ahead and throw an egg in there
it won't make a difference
that's basically what we're saying well
guys this has been great
brought to you by egg
egg
it's just fine for your trying times
i don't like it i don't like it
[Music]